it's been a busy week for the north las
vegas fire department as they battled
different fires including two last night
but they still managed to come together
for their annual awards ceremony
this morning thanks so much for joining
us tonight at six o'clock i'm sasha
loftis
8 news reporter victoria saha was there
she has the details for us
honor and recognize some special
firefighters as well as an aspiring one
who has already proven how dedicated he
is to the north las vegas fire
department
meet divyan lara who is well on his way
to become a firefighter the 19 year old
is part of the north las vegas fire
department explorers program
while being in the sports program i'm
able to connect with different people
and see how
everyone is going towards their certain
goal
lara was recognized as the explorer of
the year because of his willingness to
be part of the north las vegas fire
department
lara was 14 when he first tried out for
the program that brings in teens to
shadow firefighters
but he didn't meet the age requirement
then at 15 and a half he was able to
make it
but last year a brain tumor put a halt
to his passion
i wasn't able to remember anything not
even to get home
from work and work is like down the
street
but it was it was kind of it was hard
but his goal of being a firefighter
wasn't forgotten after his recovery he
jumped right back into action like a
true firefighter
we had to be there at 7 30 but i was
there at 7. the award ceremony was also
a day to promote two firefighters and
recognize several members of each
department for their heroic efforts
during such a difficult
year they're being asked more of
they're doing it in conditions that are
less than
perfect so it's good to just at least
once a year be able to pull them up and
recognize them for some of the
huge successes that they've had the
deputy chief also says they pride
themselves for being a small group
but doing their best with what they have
in the newsroom victoria saha
8 news now